man spürt wie eine last von ihm abfällt
hoffnung liegt in der luft
seit vergangenen freitag patient 1095
system vom us-militär gebauten
behelfskrankenhaus auf dem new yorker
messegelände chinesen entlassen wird
die letzten patienten werden verlegt in
die regulären krankenhäuser die wieder
kapazitäten frei haben
es sieht nach einer trendwende aus in
dieser katastrophe
die kurve ist nicht einfach gefallen
die new yorker haben sie gebogen sie
haben die kurve verändert weil sie zu
hause geblieben sind masken getragen
haben und so weiter
new york diese sonst so lebendige stadt
hat sich mit macht der solche
entgegengestellt
sechs wochen liegt die weltmetropole und
stehen so real unsere fahrt durch die
häuserschluchten durch die sich sonst
hunderttausende drängen auf ihrem weg
zur arbeit
menschenleer der finanzdistrikt
chinatown oder die touristenmagneten wie
der times square und daran soll sich bis
zum 15
auch nichts ändern
während die meisten new yorker zu hause
bleiben haben andere so viel zu tun wie
noch nie zuvor in ihrem leben an der u
bahn station vor dem metropolitan
krankenhaus treffen wir die intensiv
schwester aischa johnson
sie hat sich freiwillig gemeldet um zu
helfen kommt aus florida
es ist so schlimm
new york hat es so hart getroffen ich
habe mir gedacht ich muss da einfach
helfen um die krankenschwestern hier zu
entlasten die überschwemmt werden mit so
vielen opfern
wie schlimm die situation noch immer ist
er fährt auch doris peyman jeden tag ich
habe heute 50-jährigen allein zwischen
zehn und zwölf
die versuchen nicht umzubringen
morrissey ist seit mehr als 40 jahren im
geschäft ihr kleines
bestattungsunternehmen ist eine one man
oder besser gesagt eine one-woman-show
das geschäft mit der letzten ruhe lief
immer gut und krisensicher vor der tür
ihr maserati cabrio was aber da in den
letzten wochen in new york passiert sagt
so etwas habe sie noch nicht erlebt das
ganze system stünde vor dem kollaps
es werde immer schwerer die bestattungen
der vielen toten zu mensch normalerweise
habe ich zwei beerdigungen die woche
oder 100 im jahr
das kann ich managen das jetzt hier kann
ich nicht mehr managen ich brauch
verstärkung
es ist wie ein wirbelsturm ich versuche
das alles zu organisieren
ich nenne das hier mein r traffic
control report wer wann wo aber eins sag
ich dir an meinem geburtstag nächste
woche werde ich nicht arbeiten ein
lieferant kommt vorbei sagt er habe eine
palette mit schutzausrüstung für sie
eine palette sollte ich der mit einer
ganzen palette
ich habe das nicht bestellt
das kommt vom gouverneur alle
bestattungsunternehmen bekommen das
jetzt okay ich mache dir die garage auf
und dann sehen wir weiter
ich brauche hilfe denn für die palette
muss erst mal platz geschaffen werden
du vom fernsehen du hilfst mir derlei
sagt muss raus aus der garage und rheine
die kapelle alles muss schnell gehen bei
doris salmon dieser tag denn statt zwei
beerdigungen die woche hat sie jetzt
mehr als 20 gleich kommt die nächste
familie und deren ruhe wolle sie nicht
stören
mein telefon klingelt das wusste auch
hier irgendwo sein
der anruf den doors bekommt macht klar
dass die dinge langsam aus dem ruder
laufen
das war ein anruf vom medical center
brooklyn nämlich gefragt haben wann ich
den verstorbenen xy abhole der am
zweiten april von uns gegangen ist
ich habe ihm gesagt ich kenne den
verstorbenen gut denn ich habe ihn schon
vor zwei drei wochen beerdigt in new
jersey sechs mal besser die marke an dem
verstorbenen der da in einer
leichenhalle liegt denn das ist nicht
mehr so und so den habe ich nämlich
schon abgeholt erklärt die sache jetzt
mal besser
sonst wirst du verklagt
new york diese stadt die sich rühmt für
jedes problem eine lösung zu finden tut
sich schwer mit den vielen toten in die
solche fordert was 19.000 menschen haben
in den vergangenen zwei monaten ihr
leben gelassen
für 2000 aber nur reichen die
kapazitäten der leichten in kühlers dann
werden die toten zwischengelagert werden
sie oft unter chaotischen bedingungen
verstaut und registriert wie sie
abgeholt werden können wir haben uns mit
eric fremden verabredet er hat sich
anheuern lassen für einen der härtesten
jobs die es derzeit in new york gibt er
hat in den clustern gearbeitet ist
eigentlich bilderrahmen bauer wir waren
alle nicht vorbereitet auf das das war
keine leichenhallen krude ich dabei
getreten bin das war eine kur von leuten
die das geld brauchten und zu einer
leichten hallen crew wurden
wir haben den job im job gelernt er
zeigt uns fotos aus dem inneren der
laster die er selber aufgenommen hat es
ist der blanke horror der einem da
entgegenschlägt so etwas siehst du nur
bei einem genozid oder bei massenmorden
du siehst das noch nicht mal in filmen
es ist einfach zu viel bis zu 110
leichen in einem anhänger der nur für 40
gedacht ist oft nur eingewickelt in
einfache leinentücher weil es keine
leichensäcke gibt eric und seine crew
bauen regale in die kühllaster um die
leichen besser zu organisieren und
schließlich identifizieren zu können
er hat lange mit sich gerungen diese
bilder zu zeigen sich dann aber dafür
entschieden damit die menschen in der
debatte um die schnelle öffnung des
landes verstehen worüber sie reden
bei coop 19 geht es nicht darum den job
zu verlieren
es geht darum deine mutter zu verlieren
und ich habe viele mütter in den
anhängern gesehen
ich habe 300 männer new yorker mitbürger
in diesen anhängern gesehen die story
von kogit 19 sind diese anhänger eine
unvorstellbar hohe opferzahl die jedes
system schockt und jede lösung
darum teile ich die bilder im ganzen
land gibt es demonstrationen von
politisch organisierten gruppen die die
ausgangs beschränkungen aufheben wollen
sie demonstrieren stehen in großen
gruppen eng zusammen und das ohne masken
nach ihrer 13 stunden schicht treffen
wir die krankenschwester lee johnson
wieder
sie ärgert sich über diese leute das
regt mich wirklich auf das sind die
leute die ich dann auf der
intensivstation pflegen muss um die ich
weine für die ich schwitze damit sie
weiterleben können
es ist nicht so wie es in den medien
darüber kommt nicht so wie es dir
freunde erzählen es ist viel schlimmer
wie überfordert das system ist macht
auch diese bilder klar
vergangene woche muss die polizei bei
einem bestattungsunternehmen im
stadtteil brooklyn anrücken aus zwei
mieters dann kommen strenge gerüche in
den lastern
mehrere dutzend verwesende leichen
anwohner hatten den geruch bemerkt
es wird wärmer es ist frühling
jetzt kannst du es riechen sehr schlimm
das sind menschen die auf dieser welt
geliebt haben und jetzt landen sie in
clustern übereinander gestapelt
garagen und kühlräume wieder
bestattungsunternehmer laufen über viele
wissen nicht mehr wohin mit all den
toten werden oder druck gesetzt von den
krankenhäusern die leichen abzuholen
weil die selbst keinen platz mehr haben
morrissey man hat wird das verhalten der
kollegen kein verständnis was machst du
denn mit 50 toten die eingeäschert
werden müssten die krematorien aber
unter der last zusammengebrochen sind
du musst sie lagern und es wird wärmer
zum glück waren april kalt aber es wird
jetzt wärme also brauchst du einen
kühllaster wenn du nach den regeln
spielst den hätte er sich zuvor besorgen
müssen und nicht danach
in der branche gebe es ein spruch
erzählte & stories du kannst es schnell
oder richtig machen
sie würde bei allen ihrer kunden darauf
achten dass die sich auch in diesen
zeiten in würde von ihren angehörigen
verabschieden könnten und sie erzählt
uns noch von einer sache die in den
vergangenen wochen besonders aufgefallen
sein
ich habe es praktisch mit fast allen
ethnischen gruppen zu tun außer mit
weißem die wenigen weißen luft da hatte
haben sich chur wird 19 in den pflege-
und altenheim angefangen aber die
latinos und die afroamerikaner die leben
oft sehr beengt mit vielen leuten in
einer kleinen wohnung eine infizierte
draußen kommt zurück und infiziert alle
ich habe vor zwei tagen eine mutter und
ihren sohn beerdigt und nächste woche
werde ich wieder eine mutter und ihren
sohn
fast zwei drittel aller opfer stammen
aus der black & braun community auf
brutale art und weise fördere das virus
ein noch sehr viel größeres problem ans
tageslicht erklärt danny williams der
public advocate new yorks der zweite
mann der stadt und scharfer kritiker des
bürgermeisters und des gouverneurs das
virus selbst diskriminiert nicht aber es
deckt die ungleichheiten der
verschiedenen communitys auf die wir
viel zu lange versucht haben zu
ignorieren wir sehen jetzt wie unter
einem vergrößerungsglas auf diese
communitys und seen all das was wir nie
angesprochen haben und was jetzt
explodiert in einem perfekten sturm der
ungleichheit die einkommen in diesem
communitys oft niedrig die mieten hoch
oft bleibe nicht genug für gesunde
lebensmittel oder wenn überhaupt eine
gute krankenversicherung
die folge ein schlechter allgemeiner
gesundheitszustand der diese gruppe
jetzt besonders anfällig mache
oben drauf kommt noch was er dann getan
wir haben gesagt bleibt alle zu hause
aber die systemrelevanten arbeiter
müssen raus in der tendenz bedeutet das
dass die die zu hause bleiben können er
die wohlhabenden sind wir sehen das in
diesen stadtteilen die todesraten nicht
so hoch sind aber 75 prozent der
systemrelevanten arbeiter sind schwarze
und latinos
wir haben gesagt ihr geht raus und
haltet die stadt am laufen
bei doris in der kapelle treffen wir auf
a feature paris heute wird ihr vater
beerdigt es dann co at 19 gestorben
schon gleich zu beginn der krise im märz
sowie ihr onkel und ihr cousin neben den
strukturellen nachteilen der black and
braun community hätte es noch ein
anderes problem gegeben das aber würde
alle betreffen
ich denke dass es für meinen vater
besser ausgegangen wäre wären wir uns
alle bewusst gewesen was da vor sich
geht er war dauernd bei meinem cousin
krankenhaus bisher gestorben ist
in den medien wurde die sache damals
noch runter gespielt
das ganze war wie eine tickende
zeitbombe
es wird dann gehört haben was los ist
war es für ihn zu spät
jetzt hat sie sorgen um ihren mann andré
auch er ein so genannter
systemrelevanter arbeite jeden tag
draußen in der stadt unterwegs
sie hat angst als er sich das virus
einfangen und mit nach hause bringt in
die kleine mietwohnung in der sie mit
ihren beiden kleinen kindern leben bevor
er in die wohnung kommt wird er mit
einem desinfektionsmittel ab gesprüht
noch immer geht die angst um in new york
vor einer solche die doris die
bestattungs unternehmerin so beschreibt
es ist die wiederkehr vom schwarzen tod
nur dass wir nicht im mittelalter leben
jeden tag kämpft die krankenschwester
lee johnson mit ihren kolleginnen und
kollegen um jedes leben viele patienten
haben sie an die krankheit verloren eine
große psychische belastung für alle
wir weinen zusammen nehmen uns in den
arm trösten uns meine familie versteht
nicht wirklich was ich hier durch mache
aber die anderen schwestern verstehen
ist wir halten zusammen
[Musik]
in keiner stadt der welt seien bislang
mehr menschen an cobit 19 gestorben als
in new york city
dutzende neue kühllaster hat die stadt
jetzt angemietet um vielen toten
aufzubewahren ist die beerdigt werden
können
das aber kann noch monate dauern langsam
erst wird das ganze ausmaß der
katastrophe klar
[Musik]